bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal
préparé par la rédaction de tv 78 c'est
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale tout
de suite les titres de ce mercredi 9
juin qu'une semaine quasiment avant le
début du baccalauréat 2021 une première
édition sous la nouvelle formule mise en
place par le gouvernement avec
l'apparition du grand oral invités et
charline avenay la rectrice de
l'académie de versailles dans cette
édition également rencontre avec un
élève de terminale
entre préparation et appréhension en
cette année particulière marquée par la
crise sanitaire son témoignage
l'acte iii du déconfinement ce mercredi
le couvre-feu passe de 21h à 23h et
plusieurs restrictions sont levées
notamment pour les piscines accessible
de nouveau à tous les publics avec
protocole sanitaire reportage à la
piscine salvador allende des clayes sous
bois
et puis cap de frein pour la 22e édition
du cycle mythe le championnat inter
collèges de match d'improvisation
théâtrale de saint quentin en yvelines
cette année pas de compétition mais un
final qui se déroulait ce mardi à la
merise attrape on parlera également
sport tout à l'heure avec le rugby club
de plaisir qui organisait ce mercredi
une journée de détection
l objectif recruter les jeunes talents
de sa future académie
nj - 8 avant le début des épreuves du
baccalauréat cette année c'est en plus
l'entrée en vigueur de la nouvelle
réforme nouvelle formule réforme est
donc par le ministère de l'éducation
nationale après une année compliquée au
vu de la situation sanitaire le bac est
perturbé seulement deux épreuves vont
être passés par les lycéens qui sont en
pleine préparation invité dans un
instant à charline avenel avec qui nous
avons échangé cet après-midi m est
d'abord bérengère bourgoin a rencontré
un élève du ministre denis
épreuve phare mais redoutée de ce bac
nouvelle version le grand oral le 22
juin nathan se pliera à l'exercice il a
dû choisir et faire valider deux
questions liées à sa filière les
sciences et technologies de l'industrie
et du développement durable alors le
principe du grand oral c'est en trois
parties donc la première partie c'est on
a notre question que le jury choisit
donc il en prend une b2 après on parle
pendant 5 minutes sur cette question
après on a un échange de dix minutes
là où ils vont nous poser des questions
par rapport aux cinq minutes précédentes
et après ça on parle pendant cinq
minutes de notre orientation là ou là où
les peuples et les intervenants ils
peuvent nous poser des questions
le baccalauréat 2021 commencera le 17
juin prochain
la plupart des matières sont passés en
contrôle continu
au programme en plus du grand oral les
élèves passeront la philosophie bas le
bac on veut
je prépare en fin d'année là du coup
parce que il nous reste que deux
épreuves c'est le reste est annulé donc
on affine haut et on
quand orale bon bah philo on révise
malgré tout les textes qu'on a et le
grand oral faut préparer ces deux
questions plus la partie orientation les
confinements ont aussi impacter la
préparation des lycéens avec la
fermeture des lycées et la mise en place
de demi jauge ils n'ont pas eu
l'occasion de faire des examens blancs
pas préparé on n'a pas vraiment fait
doral lancôme ans seulement en faire
pour préparer ce grand oral b on a fini
les cours demain donc
ba s'est fait à larache en soit on n'est
pas prêtre près de 19 mille autres
élèves yvelinois s'attaqueront à ces
deux épreuves
en espérant que nathan fera partie des
heureux bacheliers de cette année ce
sont même très exactement 18 mille sept
cent soixante quatre candidats qui sont
inscrits au baccalauréat 2021 toutes
filières confondues général
technologique et professionnel très de
68500 au niveau de l'académie de
versailles qui regroupe également les
départements de l'essonne du val d'oise
et des hauts-de-seine un baccalauréat
2021 qui débutera donc le 17 juin avec
l'épreuve de philosophie pour les
terminales
l'épreuve écrite anticipées de français
pour les premières et le premier grand
oral de l'histoire l'épreuve vitrine de
la réforme du baccalauréat se déroulera
lui entre le 21 juin et le 2 juillet
pour en parler avec mon visioconférence
se charline avenel bonjour et rectrice
de l'académie de versailles merci d'être
avec nous des épreuves de philosophie et
du grand oral dont qui sont bien
maintenues avec des ajustements donc on
va parler dans un instant une part
importante notamment du contrôle continu
pourquoi fallait-il maintenir ces
épreuves malgré le contexte que l'on
connaît cette année particulière marquée
par les demies jauge des cours parfois
en distance yale une année qui a été
particulière pour pour les élèves
il fallait tenir ce baccalauréat le plus
possible avec son esprit parce que le
baccalauréat c'est une étape importante
qui signe la fin du lycée second qui a
pris et qui est une forme de redémarrage
va ce qui suit vers l'enseignement
supérieur donc en ce sens à voir ce
moment solennel avec des épreuves qui
sont appréciés avec bienveillance dans
le contexte qu'on connaît
eh bien c'était important et
particulièrement sur des épreuves qui
sont nouvelles comme celle du grand
choral parce que ce grand oral il a un
sens
très important de jonction entre le
lycée et la vie qui suit le luthier bon
parler dans un instant c'est un vague
dont le contrôle continu va prendre une
grande part 82% dans la note finale et
18% pour les épreuves de philosophie et
du grand oral et donc des ajustements et
l'épreuve de spécialités les épreuves de
spécialité qui a été prévu en mars ont
été annulés pour la philosophie il y
aura quatre sujets au choix au lieu de
trois et c'est la meilleure note entre
celles de l'épreuve et celle du cot du
contrôle continu qui sera retenue en ce
qui concerne le grand oral les élèves
auront finalement le droit à leurs notes
de brouillon et le jury sera au courant
des chapitres non étudiées vous le
disiez un instant la stratégie adoptée
c'est celle de la bienveillance pour
cette épreuve pour ces épreuves
absolument éviter c'était vraiment tout
à la fois de maintenir ces épreuves
parce qu'elles sont importantes et en
même temps de pouvoir de pouvoir ajuster
de pouvoir regarder avec le plus de
bienveillance et le mettre au monde de
ce baccalauréat
ce qui ne veut pas dire que nous allons
être moins exigeant mais en tout cas
bien méliand assurément et je pense
qu'avec les ajustements que vous venez
de rappeler le au ticket pour rassurer
les élèves et les leur faire passer dans
des conditions de sérénité
tenant compte de cet ami si particulière
qui l'ont connu et donc les amenant je
le crois vers la réussite
mais je précise qu'est également des
ajustements ont eu lieu pour les
épreuves anticipées de français pour les
élèves de première un plus de sujets au
choix à l'écrit également moins de texte
a étudié à l'oral avec aussi le jour de
l'épreuve le choix entre deux textes qui
sera donc fait part par l'examinateur
malgré ces ajustements est ce que vous
comprenez charlie nadal qui est malgré
tout une forme d'inquiétude de la part
des élèves des professeurs aussi face
peut-être un manque de préparation
l'année particulière je le disais tout à
l'heure
entre2000 jauge cours en distance yale
c'est une année éprouvante qu'ont vécu
les élèves et les professeurs crois
qu'il faut vraiment se rassurer être
très serein aussi bien les enseignants
que les élèves
si on prend l'exemple du grand oral les
choses on est vraiment été très préparée
le confesseur ont été formés on a fait
1500 sessions de formation pour les
enseignants eux-mêmes on a fait des
master class nous n'en avons fait pour
les élèves également dans un instant je
pense qu'on mettra on parlera du
dispositif que nous entendent pas sur
cette dernière ligne droite mais
vraiment très sincèrement les choses ont
été préparées aussi bien pour les
professeurs parce que c'était important
rose et leur premier grand oral par
exemple est évidemment pour les élèves
qui passent les premiers
ce premier baccalauréat nous allons y
revenir à ce dispositif je voulais vous
faire rebondir justement sur ce que vous
disiez à propos du grand oral qui est la
grande nouveauté de ce mac nouvelle
formule avec une épreuve qui a duré 20
minutes 20 minutes qui porte sur les
connaissances de première et terminale
sur le projet d'orientation également 20
minutes donc à l'oral pour certains ça
va être une première confrontation avec
cette prise de parole en public ça c'est
essentiel de proposer cet exercice
justement un moment où les élèves vont
continuer leur cursus peut-être
poursuivre avec des études supérieures
aussi se confronter au monde
professionnel
oui le gran torino france c'est un
exercice qui est fondamental pour
l'avenir des élèves à la fois parce
qu'ils vont faire d'enseignement
supérieur mais évidemment aussi plus
loin dans leur vie professionnelle
pourquoi parce que second tour à halle
il permet de faire pire chose d'abord
argumenté et dans la vie on a besoin
d'un vraiment
deux structures et à partir d'une
question qui est posée son coco c'est ce
qu'ils apprennent à faire c'est ce à
quoi ils se sont préparés qu'on s'était
pas la deuxième chose dans un grand oral
c'est qu'on écoute on ne sait pas que
parler mon écoute et c'est important
d'entendre le jury d'entendre l'altérité
d'entendre dans une interview qu sion ce
que l'autre nous dit et puis le dernier
la verrait chose c'est qu'on apprend à
parler
la maîtrise de la parole est évidemment
essentiel dans les compétences dans
l'enseignement supérieur mais évidemment
également dedans dans la vie
professionnelle
donc c'est pourquoi cette épreuve est
une épreuve ça est aussi importante
vous allez signaler que c'était paraît
comporter une petite partie également
qui parle du candidat qui part de son
orientation qui parle de son avenir mais
vraiment je les ai vus encore milliards
dans un lycée cette partie d'épreuve où
l'on parle de soi elle est très
importante quand on va à un entretien
d'embauché
on doit parler de soi quand on réfléchit
à ses choix d'orientation et bien
l'avoir formulées dans le grand oral au
moment où on a les résultats par coups
reçus
c'est important voilà pourquoi cette
fois c'est une épreuve jonction entre
leur vie les uns et puis surtout
l'europe et d'ailleurs l'académie de
versailles se mobilisent pour ce grand
oral vous serez à 18 heures l'horaire de
ce journal normalement c'est pour ça
qu'on enregistre cette interview en live
sur le compte instagram de l'académie de
versailles
quel est le programme de ce live est-ce
que vous allez répondre du cou à des
questions justement des élèves que
peuvent avoir les élèves à une semaine
du début du bac
le jeune ilan et payet beaucoup moyens
pour accompagner les élèves dans ce
grand oral
les hommes eux
un an webinaire mon master class mais en
professeurs les ont accompagnés j'ai vu
des ateliers ça dans les dents mais ces
délits par exemple les amenant à être le
plus près possible de cette épreuve mais
avec ce live sur les grands tours ' il
s'agit d'accompagner la dernière ligne
droite et donc ce n'est pas moi qui vais
répondre aux questions des élèves et ce
n'est d'ailleurs pas moi qui posera ses
questions mais le live c'est utiliser un
média cannes les jeunes qu'ils
connaissent et donc nous aurons une
jeune fille une élue du conseil
académique de vigny ciel qui posera des
questions à cyril delaire cyril de l'est
qui est professeur d'arts vois toi à
sciences po qui d'ailleurs a été à
l'origine d'un rapport qui a été repris
par un ministre pour concevoir cet
effort de grand soir c'est un rêve que
si on rate on pourra bien sûr retrouver
sur le compte instagram de l'académie de
versailles je précise aussi qu'à partir
de demain et jusqu'au 20 juin donc
veille du début du grand oral il y aura
également des vidéos de courtes vidéos
qui seront a publié sur le compte
instagram de l'académie de versailles
elle justement pour informer sur sur le
grand oral
une dernière chose charline adèle sur
l'organisation des épreuves il ya eu
quelques couacs dans d'autres académies
notamment dans le nord et le pas de
calais avec des professeurs convoqué
pour des épreuves sans avoir les
compétences requises absence de
convocation est ce que à l'académie de
versailles tout est prêt pour une bonne
organisation justement de ces épreuves
on est à une semaine louis jours très
exactement du début du bac 2021 les et
les enseignants ne sont pas tous
convoqués à l'heure où je vous parle ce
sera fait
dc d'ici quelques heures donc voilà on
est confiant sur sûr cela évidemment ces
derniers ajustements sont fondamentaux
parce que il s'agit de mettre devant
tous les élèves les bons enseignants
compte tenu des choix de mes choix de
spécialités est donc ce sera fait ce
sera fait à ses atouts banc mais on n'a
pas encore évoqué tout le monde
dernière chose le protocole sanitaire en
vigueur était lequel sûr at il justement
pour ce box un protocole qui permet de
maintenir les distances d'avoir le mas
des préconisations évidemment en cas de
virus avérée ou de symptômes pour les
élèves qui sont concernés ne se
présentent pas aux épreuves et auront la
possibilité de repasser leur épreuve
ultérieure merci charline abel d'avoir
été avec nous et je le rappelle vous
êtes la rectrice de l'académie de
versailles
retour en direct face à ce nouveau baky
à cette épreuve du grand oral
l'opposition des syndicats d'enseignants
plusieurs dénoncent un manque de
préparation en raison de cette année
tronquée par l'épidémie de colis de 19
ils demandent notamment plus de clarté
dans les consignes données par leur
hiérarchie
interview express collectées par bixente
n'a rien senti steban ses
caractéristiques il fut toute la
politique qui a mené kaman et jean
michel blanquer
depuis le début de la pandémie c'est à
dire quoi les annonces ont été faites
tardivement on est dans la préparation
la plus totale il ya eu des inégalités
de traitement énorme entre des élèves
aussi bien aux collèges qu'en lycées
liés à la mise en distance partielle des
élèves qui est très variable selon les
établissements et il a vraiment fallu
batailler pour que tout ceci soit a pris
en compte
et alors qu'il est il ya encore un grand
nombre de problèmes qui ne sont pas
réglés
mais donc ce qu'on a demandé dans la
mesure où certaines il a été testé que
certaines épreuves se tient quand même
qu'il y ait un maximum de 4 nationale
qu'ils soient maintenues mais aussi des
protocoles sanitaires strictes qu'ils
soient mises en oeuvre et à l'heure
qu'il est on là aussi assez peu
d'informations sur ces sur ces
protocoles
ah bah oui ça certainement une année qui
a été tronquée et qui a été tronquée par
la pandémie avec une mise en place de la
réforme qu'il fallait mettre en place
coûte que coûte alors qu'on était
vraiment dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles
donc oui évidemment les élèves sont
pénalisés pénalise aussi parce qu'il a
fallu voilà mettre en oeuvre à toute
force une réforme avec ce grand oral qui
est de plus en plus d'appareils comme un
totem qu'on veut maintenir parce qu'il
symbolise la réforme sans aucune prise
en compte de ce qu'a été cette année
scolaire à l'année scolaire précédente
dans la cueillette également ce mercredi
9 juin marque une nouvelle étape dans le
déconfinement un couvre-feu plus tard à
23h et des établissements autorisés à
rouvrir par mieux les piscines aux
clayes-sous-bois la piscine salvador
allende a accueilli à nouveau le public
après huit mois de fermeture
célia 200 go et bérangère bourgoin était
présente sur place il était temps parce
que là ça commence à bien faire
premières brasses pour les nageurs des
clayes-sous-bois les piscines
intérieures sont désormais autorisés à
rouvrir
il y avait là que cet après midi là pour
accéder au cran passant nous avons aussi
poster des messages sur le
sur les réseaux sociaux pour que
l'information
ou se propage rapidement à temps nous
attendons les les usagers avec
impatience là je vois je vois autour de
nous que les gens reviennent
progressivement
cela faisait huit mois que la piscine
salvador allende aux clayes-sous-bois
été fermée au public lambda
les nageurs étaient donc ravis de
retrouver le chemin des bassins
on attendait avec beaucoup d'impatience
avec les enfants on a profité de
d'accompagner les enfants club de
natation et après on enchaîne sur le
petit moment de détente habituellement
vient trois fois par semaine donc ouais
on aime bien nager donc là les problèmes
de dos donc voila c'était ça manquait
énormément avec le télétravail le dos on
avait hâte en protocole strict reste
nécessaire port du masque obligatoire
jusqu'à la douche interdiction de
prendre une douche en sortie fléchage au
sol et quasi condamné les gens viennent
avec leur leurs affaires se changent
rapidement dans les vestiaires prennent
leur douche nage et repartent dans un
autre vestiaire pour éviter les
croisements une jauge a également été
mise en place la capacité de personnes
en simultané a été réduite de 50%
ce sont donc deux cent soixante
personnes qui peuvent nager en même
temps la piscine est accessible sans
réservation est ouverte aux horaires
habituels
un mot de rugby à partir de la rentrée
prochaine le club de la ville va ouvrir
une académie
le club de la ville de plaisir une
académie pour les jeunes de 16 à 23 ans
ce mercredi une journée de détection se
déroulait donc au stade robert barran
pour recruter les futurs membres de
cette académie de cette académie le
reportage de mickaël millero une dizaine
de jeunes joueurs un seul objectif
intégrer la future académie de rugby a
plaisir à la rentrée prochaine c'est
rugbyman ont bravé les chaleurs de ce
mercredi 9 juin pour se soumettre à une
journée de détection organisée par le
club pour reconnaître les meilleurs des
tests de haut niveau ont été mises en
place alors là il y aura plusieurs
plusieurs séquences il y aura une
séquence physique avec des tests de
vitesse et ensuite y aura des séquences
de jeu de manipulation voilà qu'on
puisse observer la technique et
le sens tactique des joueurs quoi
pendant le jeu et des choses qu'on voit
très très vite effectivement après il ya
des choses il faut qu'on mette en place
un peu un peu de jeu de mouvement pour
voir un peu les qualités de deux des
joueurs et des joueuses
ces tests vont permettre de sélectionner
des joueurs de 16 à 23 ans du
département des yvelines au total ils
seront une vingtaine de joueurs et
joueuses intégré cette structure mois de
septembre elle sera encadrée par le club
les premiers plus d'heures de rugby aux
sportifs on va travailler toute la
semaine en fait on va leur proposer un
planning hebdomadaire avec 2 5 à 12
heures en plus de rugby individuelles en
plus de leur séance collective
une formule qui a séduit les joueurs
présents sur place c'est une opportunité
pour en faire plus et être avec les amis
y a plus d'accompagnement pense que ça
peut amener un autre niveau quelconque
auquel on joue déjà ça peut être une
bonne opportunité je trouve pour me
perfectionner rugby enfin on peut
toujours s'améliorer et puis
l'accompagnement à l'air d'être plutôt
sympa comme ça nous a déjà été un peu
expliqué donc ça peut être une bonne une
bonne expérience
si j'ai détecté à un patient et a hâte
de voir la suite
une nouvelle journée de détection est
programmée ce samedi 12 juin à 14 heures
au stade robert barran de plaisir on
referme ce journal avec un classique à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la 22e édition
du cycle mythe le championnat inter
collèges de match d'improvisation
théâtrale c'était ce mardi 8 juin
l'événement a pris place à la merise
attrape cette année pas de compétition
mais un final une centaine de collégiens
s'est affrontés sur la patinoire pour ce
qu'ils étaient pour la plupart leur
premier match de l'année justin brasier
et nicolas landry des matchs
d'improvisation théâtrale intercollèges
déclic théâtre a souhaité maintenir le
cycle mise cette année l'événement a
pris place à la merise de trappes pour
se préparer
les collégiens ont eu des cours en visio
entre particularité de cette édition
seuls des matchs intra collège ont eu
lieu l'événement était l'occasion de se
rencontrer pour la première fois de
l'année les enfants ont dû s'adapter
rapidement
avec cette année compliquée
l'arrivée aujourd'hui au spectacle la
plupart ils étaient très contents mais
très stressé parce que bon c'est ça non
il ya un premier match entre au collège
et un deuxième match avec un autre
collège il rencontre d'autres personnes
c'est magique vraiment les matches c'est
magique ça les fait progresser sa laisse
évoluer là ils sont passés d'un petit
match sans patinoire sans musique avec
très peu de public à ça aujourd'hui
six collèges ont participé à l'événement
les collèges le village pour b et
gagarine de trappes la mare au sol de
coignières les soldes lui en cours et
giacometti est de montigny le bretonneux
ça fait plaisir parce que j'ai arrangé
les choses et avec l'équipe ça fait
plaisir de nous on travaille avec eux
tapez 2 ans ont fait plus de matches
avec de la musique cette erreur est là
pour poser avec de la musique et devoirs
du public surtout cette viande de cheval
pourrait bien lâcher le terrain qu'on
fait c'est vraiment
six matches ont été organisées entre les
collèges pour la finale l'objectif de
l'événement conclure les ateliers
d'impro des collèges et surtout finir
l'année sur une note positive et post il
on a subi voilà bah la visio pour faire
du théâtre les deux me jauger pas mal de
contraintes liées à l'épidémie
et bien en fait ouais il fallait que
tout le monde tous ceux qui étaient là
il fallait qu'ils puissent en profiter
donc le wef est juste pouvoir jouer en
fait et montrer qu'on peut y être et
être heureux d'y être
au total une centaine de jeunes se sont
rencontrés à la merise pour cette 22e
édition c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]